[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum baum
hi everyone how are you thanks for uh
tuning in again this is your first time
uh you're in for a treat
uh i think so um if it is your first
time i uh
ask you to uh subscribe to the podcast
give it a listen give other guests a
chance
because you might not know them but you
might just learn something from them i
know i learn
a little every day it's therapy for me
it's free therapy
that's what it is and hopefully it's a
little therapy for you but uh i'll tell
you what today's guest was uh
well we'll get into the guess it was
extraordinary and
you know i was nervous about this one
you hear me say that occasionally but
you know i know kevin but i don't know
kevin conroy the voice of batman
batman over all these years and we did
justice league unlimited together
but he was so open i was nervous that he
wasn't didn't want to get personal
didn't want to get
and i'll tell you what this is i learned
so much i know you will too and
uh it's heart-wrenching some of it is
really like uh
just some of it's beautiful some of it's
you know
talk about facing adversity um you
listen to his story
and you're gonna uh i think you're gonna
really not only appreciate him more but
appreciate life more appreciate
maybe learn something from it i i think
you will also
i've said it before great guests coming
up as well
um there's a couple that i was really
excited about getting
um and i think they're gonna be really
really swell
all my guests are amazing and they open
up and i just really appreciate it last
week
uh oliver hudson if you haven't listened
to oliver hudson
and you don't know him or whatever
listen to it trust me
talk about somebody who opens up about
you guys like my sister kate hudson's a
movie star
my mom goldie hawn's a movie star kurt
russell my dad's a movie star and i
at this point in his life he was like
i'm anxious what am i doing i'm not
and he's just so honest about things
meeting up with his biological father
which
some people out there in the world can
relate to and
check that out and if you haven't
listened to eli roth by the way another
one
director even if you don't like horror
very insightful he was the bear jew
in in glorious bastards he directed
hostile cabin fever
so many things check him out i want to
say a big thanks to
of course all my listeners out there um
it means a great deal for you to tune in
every
week i say it every week but i should
because you never know if there are new
listeners here and you hope there are
but uh please subscribe you can watch on
youtube uh ryan does a lovely job
editing
follow us on instagram at
insideyoupodcast on instagram and
facebook at insideyoupod
i believe on twitter i should know that
by now
um you know obviously i had to cancel my
live podcast with zach levi
in texas but that's par for the course
there's things going on in this world
that are out of my control and i think
that's part of like
this whole process is just sort of
saying hey it's out of your control let
it go why are you stressed why are you
irritable why are you just you know let
it go you know
so uh this past week was a little bit
tough for me uh
i had one day where nothing worked the
internet didn't work and this this
company's been just screwing me over
of course that's how you feel like
they're screwing me over but uh you know
obviously a lot of people are having
problems but uh
two guests i had to cancel two guests
right when they're about to record which
upsets me because i'm always on time i
always want to do things right and i
sometimes my friend says uh dude things
happen life happens you just gotta
hope that the person you're about to
talk to is cool and
understands and most people will
understand so thank you to my guests
uh a few days ago that i had to postpone
a great podcast i did five interviews
this week this last week and
they're fantastic and i wish i could
tell you the good news there's some good
news coming i've been saying it but uh
i'll be announcing it soon
really excited about that and uh thanks
to my sponsor
better help i think it's very fitting
for the show
better help online counseling they
didn't even ask me to say this in the
beginning but
i noticed that it does help people and
any kind of counseling
um during these times especially and all
the time to talk to someone is just
value so valuable uh another huge shout
out to my patrons i don't know if you
know what patreon is i talk about it all
the time but
people love the podcast they support on
the side they pledge they get
a bunch of stuff uh there's tears
there's a community the biggest thing
i've done i do these instagram lives
and i noticed that people have built
these friendships from this community
of uh patreon and people keep joining
and you know
i keep thinking oh they love the podcast
something well i think they actually
like each other too it's just
no it's uh it's fantastic and i thank
you all for sticking around
and being a part of this we do uh inside
of me where they get to ask me questions
i created another character who asks the
questions it's a woman
sometimes it's a dude i just like to mix
it up i get bored man i like to be
creative
there's a lot of other stuff [ __ ]
talking questions where they ask the
guest questions and
uh extra podcast bonus app for people um
sometimes there's old episodes that
aren't even around that we we dig up and
we give to our patrons and there's a
great community we talk we do youtube
lives where i play music and they have a
request line it's just for
all the all the patreons for that one
and it's amazing and uh the support is
unreal so if
you're interested in joining community i
definitely recommend patreon and
a lot of the people on there that i
consider friends
really um could uh
speak for themselves and they would say
probably the same thing i want to get
into it is there anything else i wanted
to talk about i want you know i also
want to thank hint water
hint doesn't even ask me they just give
me these waters for a couple years now
my buddy paul
he just delivers waters and it's nice
it's like they don't ever ask hey put it
on the podcast talk about it they don't
give me money i just love hitting water
i just want to say hint water thanks
you get the hint good great let's get
into the podcast
afterwards we'll be uh i'll be talking
about some other stuff but uh
let's get into it this guy is the voice
of batman for many years i've had the uh
uh the luck to to work with him the uh
he's he's a great man he's he's he lived
with robin williams he's
he's been around in a good way he's just
so knowledgeable
and so open i think you're gonna love
the crap out of this one
let's get inside of kevin
conroy it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you know conroy i'm going to blame you
in this i know
it just it just has to be computers
don't like me i don't know what it is i
like computers
anything that can go wrong will go wrong
well i'm telling you
right before we called i was going a
little
you know i don't get
it's not so much external just inside i
get this
in here in the chest and i start it's
called anxiety
yeah i i you know but it's the simple
things it's like why am i freaking out
inside why am i getting all worried
about things it just i hate when it
happens
i know yeah i know that's human do you
do it do you still get the do you ever
get
you seem so calm and collected right
it's a really good mask isn't it
well i've been meditating since i was
21.
21. is it something that's part of your
routine every day when you wake up or is
it a it was for
decades it was much more necessary when
i was younger
i was very anxiety ridden i was
i was really in knots inside and
i really needed that tool i ran six
miles every day i did everything i could
to release anxiety because i grew up
with an incredible amount of anxiety
tied up inside of me and i really had to
focus for
a while when i was younger to get rid of
that
to get that out of my life it's amazing
that at a at a young age you can
actually
understand you knew what was happening
to you right you knew that there's
something going on that's just that i
have to i have to try and do everything
i can to control it
absolutely i was drinking too much i was
doing drugs i was smoking a pack a day
and i was having seizures i i had
something called psychomotor epilepsy
that started when i was about 14.
and i'd have fits and they did all kinds
of brain scans and they said you do not
have epilepsy
but you have a a psychological condition
called long-term anxiety
and it comes from growing up in a
situation of such
anxiety such tension that your
your your nervous system has this valve
that you've developed
and it's giving you these seizures
and um it was really dramatic i mean i
once flew off my bicycle i once
fell off a roof i would have these
seizures
and um so i had to do everything i could
to
alleviate anxiety would you think
obviously i mean obviously i don't say
obviously but do you think it stemmed
from
maybe just upbringing and being around
dysfunction at all oh god it was all
about that
my father was a
i was a fall down drunk and he was a
mean drunk and he was a
old world very imperious
man he was a child of immigrants he grew
up in
hell's kitchen in new york he was an
entirely self-made man he was
he was a street kid in new york and
um a really tough one and he was born in
so it was like having a grandfather you
know he was much older
and um he was very old world
old irish and um everything had to be
very formal we were little we had to
call him sir
stuff like that and the fights in our
house growing up were just
legendary it was like growing up in um
long day's journey and tonight i mean it
was just this irish
drunk crazy
fighting clan
all my elder siblings were fighting with
my father
and my mother was very very much like
mary tyrone in long day's journey she
was very passive
she was very loving but just beaten down
by this man that she'd been married to
and um
everyone got out of that house as soon
as they could
all my older siblings who were much
older
and so at the time i got to be around 14
i was there alone
and it was insane in that house i mean
that day
my father was drunk every day and my
mother started drinking heavily
and i ended up moving out of that house
when i was 16
and moved in with a friend's family just
so i could finish high school
and they let you stay there you could
not live there it was
it was it was it was the police were
there
all the time it was crazy it was crazy
wow
so so it was it was it was screaming it
was yelling it was physical it was
alcohol it was everything
everything my god you know it's kind of
a classic you know
it's not that unusual it is well hang on
a second fortunately
it's not that unusual well i i talk
about some dysfunction that i had people
talk about their dysfunctions but then
it always
you always hear someone else's story and
you're like that was fine
you know i mean listen to kevin i mean
kevin really had it bad i feel better
i don't feel better i feel horrible for
you but i just like
it you know i talk about this all the
time but it is
you you see i'm sure you have friends or
people that like oh i actually grew up
in a normal
environment my parents didn't drink they
were kind they were loving they're still
together and you and don't you i sort of
i
i mean i envy that oh i am in awe of
families like that like
like that you know who's like that who
dietrich vader and you could tell
i love that family he and his wife and
these two kids they
adore each other they are happy together
you go into that house and it's just
functioning
loving warm and just sit there and you
think
this really does exist you know i never
saw that growing up so i love that
family they were wonderful
yeah and it's so funny because i find
myself being comforted
by going over friends houses who have
families who are together who are loving
and just going for dinner or spending
like it's me and their family
it's like lonely rose and bomb yeah and
i go there and i think i did that as a
kid i would go
to uh you know the cutters down the
street even though they were
dysfunctional but you know they were
kind of loving and the idlemans and the
shepherds and the
and i just try to i don't i don't what
is that
i don't know it's another world but yeah
i moved in with the emanuels
who was a classmate of mine in high
school just so i could finish up high
school because
uh my house was insane
completely insane what did your family
think about that though were they like
okay go stay there
fine my mother was happy about it
because she moved out at that point
moved in with her sister in upstate new
york to get away from my father my
father
it was a very very dark time in our
lives he had tried to kill himself and
he was committed
for a while and when he was released he
moved back into the house and the police
had told him he wasn't supposed to and
he just showed up
and so my mother and i got out it was
crazy i mean this is like
they write books about this kind of
stuff you tell you know i never talk
about this with anyone because
it's just so
it's so ridiculous you think wasn't
there anyone around to protect these
people
and this is you know the 1970s there
really wasn't but how long the police
got scared
the police got tired of coming to our
house you know it's that kind of thing
because no one was going to kill anybody
it was just all this insanity
and um so my mother got out i got out
and then i got a scholarship to go to
juilliard and i moved into new york when
i was 17.
and i've been supporting myself ever
since i never went back
hang on it says my internet connection
is unstable this is the [ __ ] i deal with
constantly so we're gonna keep going um
okay all right so all the crap and then
you ended up
moving you went to juilliard so by the
way during this whole time was your
father
sort of like anti-acting no son of
mine's gonna be an actor
oh he thought it was completely insane
he couldn't understand it
he just but he had so checked out at
that point
that um he
he was he was really at the bottom i
mean he
tried to kill himself when i was in high
school i mean it was just
it was very ugly and um
and at that time i was the only one left
in the house with my mother
so i was the one sent to
see him in the hospital and pick up his
car
which was covered with blood i mean it
was
for a 16 year old it was just a a truly
dark dark experience that i couldn't get
away from fast enough
so um how do you get away from that how
do you have any
my point is he didn't have any say in
what i was going to do
especially because he wasn't going to
pay for anything i was getting a
scholarship
and i was funny john houseman the day i
auditioned for juilliard i was 17 i'm
auditioning on the main stage at
juilliard
and i'm doing romeo you know and
afterwards john houseman says
well mr conroy we're clearly very
interested in having you come to
juilliard
and i was so excited and he said come up
and speak to miss harley about her
finances
no no the first he said how is it a
young man from
from westport needs financing
and i said well not everyone from
westport is wealthy a
and b i don't have a family that will
support me
and he said oh very very well very well
it's not in my business
but come up and speak to miss farley
mark miss harley
and there was a moat at the bottom of
the stage
and the audience was actually above us
and it was like called this
uh uh a
studio theater and um it was set up like
an operating room or the first row
you know it was above you looking down
right and you're watching
performances it was like viewing an
operating room but i was on this stage
and i grabbed a bar that was about eye
level
and i used to do uh gymnastics in high
school
and i grabbed the bar and i vaulted from
the stage
up into the first row without even
thinking and houseman and harley jumped
up and said
good god you're not insured yet oh
my god i don't know how i did it i just
bolted and uh that's when they said
they'd give me a scholarship
what year was that 73. because what year
was he doing the paper chase i remember
as a kid just watching
right after that well i was there before
he started his acting career
because he had been a producer and a
director he was more of an
uh impresario right and he started
acting
really late he started acting after that
yeah because then he did like a
ghost story and all these different
things yeah
wow did your dad ever by the way did he
ever see you perform
yes did he ever say hey
you're good i'm proud of you
no none of that
and you wanted that but he came to see
me
uh i was doing death trap i did the
national tour the broadway tour
and we were playing at the uh
the wilbur theater in boston i was
co-starring with brian bedford and it
was a big role he's a wonderful role
and he came up to see the play and he uh
he really didn't say anything which is
the one
he wanted to meet brian backstage when
when brian met him
after the show um
brian was a very difficult man very
difficult
but a brilliant actor and a generous
he had a generous soul and he liked me
um but he could be really difficult and
he
the next night after my father had come
brian um
summoned me to his dressing room you
know because he was the star
so i went to his dress room and he said
i'd like to talk to you about your
father
i said oh great he said
um i sensed a lot of tension between you
and i said yeah there's a lot of history
there
he said he's a very unusual man i said
yes he's very unusual
and he said let me give you a piece of
advice
when your father dies which he
eventually will
you will never get a chance to correct
that relationship
and that will haunt you for the rest of
your life
he said so my advice to you is do
everything you can while he's alive
to try and mend that bridge
oh my god i look i know
because i've i've been there with my
father but it's so true
and i did i ended up taking care of my
father in his last years
did everything i mean i was flying back
and forth between new york and l.a
because he kept getting
put in drunk wars and stuff and
i was the only one of my siblings who
was doing any of this and they'd say why
are you doing this
he was a monster waiting and i said i
kept thinking of brian
so i was with my father the night he
died
and that's an invaluable thing to have
to know that you gave a hundred percent
that you did everything humanly possible
to save this man to reach this man
and so i have no ghosts at all
my god i mean honestly you brought me to
tears almost i'm just like sitting here
um my god that is uh wonderful i had an
amazing moment with him on his last
night
because i didn't think he was gonna die
that night because he had he had come
close to the edge so many times and the
doctor met me in the hall he said oh
we're so glad we flew in from la
we may not make it through the night i
said are you serious i didn't i thought
this was just another
drunk thing he said oh no his system is
closing down wow i was with him
and we're sitting there in the dark of
this hospital room
and he looked out through the hospital
window
into the night sky and he got
this really distant stare
what they call the thousand-yard stare
and he just shook his head and he said
the great conroy
so remorsefully
so ruefully and i said what was that
dad and he didn't look at me just kept
shaking his head and he said
the great conroy
and i thought
dear god in heaven this is the best
lesson he's ever given me
how not to die you don't want to live
your life
so that at the last breath you have
you're thinking
i've wasted my life oh my god
and i thought this is an invaluable
lesson
isn't that amazing oh my gosh i mean i
was just tense this whole time listening
oddly enough it was the closest moment
we'd ever had do you think he was
taught he was obviously talking about
himself like i'm [ __ ]
i i ruined my life that's what it was
i've wasted my life who did i think i
was
what was i trying to prove so
inadvertently he gave you the best
advice of your life
almost on his last breath oh absolutely
and you felt that you knew it right then
were you emotional were you brought to
tears at this moment
i was that ended up being a very
emotional night
because it was so unexpected
and um
at that point i was the one holding the
family together i was the diplomat i was
running my father's
you know house and his accounts for him
and uh
i had to contact all of my siblings
which is the hardest thing to do i had
to do it with my grandma isn't that the
worst that
that's the worst part having to tell
each person well maybe i don't was it
oh yeah i have a brother who's mentally
ill
and and and i having to tell him was
just
he fell apart he completely fell apart
um how many years ago was that
i was 30. so it's it was 86
so it's 34 years now or something and
i'm feeling that you
you're feeling this like it was
yesterday it was a very visceral
experience
it was a pivotal time tonight too
because i knew that
i was going to take over from my brother
at that point i was going to have to be
responsible for him from then on
which i was and so it was a big
transition which i had been preparing
for
did you ever call brian and say
you know i did it i took your advice
you know i didn't isn't that terrible no
ryan and i really did drifted apart i
learned
so much from him on stage and i also
learned from him offstage like that
example
but he could be so difficult to live
with
um that we didn't really get along so
we had some famous fights on stage
actually during the performance
like almost these these subtle moments
that only you and he knew about
oh no oh no like what
like the opening at the kennedy center
which is a state event because it's part
of the you know it's a national monument
the kennedy center
so people are there like black tie and
stuff right and
brian could be such a prick on stage
he was such a diva and death trap is
about these
two writers who are sort of dueling with
each other and there
there's many many layers to the play i
don't want to get into it now it's hard
to describe
but there are points where one one
writer finds what the other writer has
been writing
and reads it aloud so you're basically
reading
a lot of exposition that the audience
has already seen
because it's like a play within a play
within a play so it's very difficult to
keep the audience's interest because
they've already seen all this stuff
and i had the first one of these
speeches
and during it brian
became just riveted by
something on the rug and he started
going down on his all fours on the rug
trying to find something and the
audience knew exactly what he was doing
and they started laughing
laughing he was just stealing focus
and he was just being ruthless about it
and totally ignoring me
and i got louder and louder it was
driving me crazy
and then i i calmed down and then his
turn
came in the next scene to do the same
thing
to have to read an expository don't tell
me you got on the floor
no i turned around and there was a
bookcase behind me
and i started looking for books in the
bookcase and i was taking it out and
look at him i just couldn't look i
couldn't find what i wanted
and he was getting louder and louder and
more strident
trying to get my attention and i was
ignoring him and the audience knew
exactly what i was doing and they were
howling that i was giving him back
exactly what he'd given me
and just at that moment i was turning
back
to him and he was getting ready to swat
me in the head with the scripts you know
we've got found a script that each of us
is working on
so just as i'm turning this script comes
and bashes me in the face
and the rivet from the script grazes my
eye and i thought he had
really hurt me and i went crazy and
we're behi on either side of this big
lawyer's partner desk and i lunged for
him
and he threw down the script and he
lunged for me
and we heard murray gitlin the stage
manager from the wing and say
gentlemen gentlemen please this is the
theater
[Laughter]
on stage performance
and we were doing all of this through
the lines of the play we never stopped
saying the lines of the play
so the whole thing you know we're doing
this play and we're like i want to
kill you and that was the subtext was i
want to kill you
and then we both sit down and we got
through the scene and the
playwright ira levin who also wrote
rosemary's baby and big playwright
had fl had come down from new york with
his family
for the kennedy center opening and he
was in the audience
and he loved it no this is i thought i
am so
fired i am never going to work in the
theater again this is my first big job
after juilliard this is my first big
break
i'm out i'm out they're going to
blackball me he comes to my dressing
room he says
you were brilliant it was incredible it
was like watching hamlet where did you
find all that in my play
so you guys they thought it was part of
it yeah we kept saying the lines
we were just playing it this hostile
anger
fury at each other but we've never
stopped broken out of character and what
did you did he say anything afterwards
like i'm sorry
no brian didn't know how to say i'm
sorry you know
i think if you probably if you notice
any similarities in someone that
your father might have had or drinking
or things are there certain things
triggers that you're like
can't be around that person that's
something that's just that's that's too
much for me that's
i can't deal with that selfishness to
the point of
narcissism i find impossible
to be around and when someone like that
comes into my life
i tend to cut them out and distance
myself from i just don't even try to
deal with them because there's no cure
for narcissism
for that kind of selfishness um
i have no patience for it it's just
amazing how
you could have easily went downhill and
said you know poor me
and sort of with your upbringing
i mean a lot of people do they just go
you go one way or the other
right it's the hand of you make choices
it is a choice
absolutely i made a very conscious
choice when i was 21
to stop drinking stop drugging stop
smoking
because once i got out of that house
oddly enough when i was 17 and i got an
apartment i was living in new york i was
robin williams was my roommate i was at
juilliard
with the most amazing actors who were
all much older than me
and they were such incredibly talented
people i felt so
out of my league um
and i started drinking
you think after what i saw growing up it
would be the last thing i would do
but it was just like it was like
quicksand
pulling me in it was this irresistible
force
and the smoking and
i just realized on my 21st birthday i
thought it is sink or swim
you have one choice to make you can live
or you can slowly kill yourself
the way your parents did you felt that
way you felt that strongly like this is
it
because you were a big drinker right
when you were drinking it wasn't just
one drink
you drank i drank starting at like 17.
so 21 i stopped everything yeah that's
amazing that takes an incredible
willpower
i've never been a drinker but you know
it's hard for me not to have a smoke
every once in a while it's hard for me
not to smoke a little pot every once in
a while
well three times a week you know it's uh
uh you know i i i have the demons man i
definitely
we all do and it's just no you know you
know sometimes the older you get you're
just like oh i want to feel
like i felt when i was in my 20s that
you know you just didn't care and you
were indestructible and you had endless
energy you didn't feel about
you didn't think about oh it's going
gonna be a 15-hour day on set you didn't
care you're like you didn't think about
hours
you didn't even register yeah and now it
just seems like
how long is that gonna take how long do
i have to be the
how long is it do you see that do you do
that god of course
yeah but the whole aging thing is so
weird because it creeps
up on you i mean there's this wonderful
groucho marx line that la is the only
place in the world where you fall asleep
by the pool and you wake up and you're
87. i love that image
because it's so true because there's no
sense of seasons
that you just turn around and suddenly
you're 10 years older 15 years older and
you think what happened
yeah but life is like that too like
think just giving
describing that that moment at the
kennedy center with brian that i was
describing to you
i was i was living it again i was right
in it to me that happened yesterday
and yet that was
40 over 40 years ago yeah
i'm older than i look you look great
i don't you do look great you can you
have so much energy i mean look
you said i don't have time for
narcissism i don't have time for this
i'm living my life
your father when he said the great
conroy you know what went through your
mind and
you you know exactly what it meant he's
way he wasted his life and i'm not gonna
do that
i mean these are all obviously they're
they're they're singing
in my head i could you know it really
makes me think
but is it something that you have to
think about almost all the time
to just make sure you're living in the
moment to make sure you're
going day by day and not rushing through
it yeah i do i have to
remind myself all the time i hate that i
hate having to
relearn a lesson that i've learned five
20 times you're going through it again
and you think
i've been here before i knew this
already
and yet i'm here again right there was a
wonderful book
that came out i was like 40 years ago
called prisoners of childhood and um
it was re-released as uh
under a different title but it was by a
psychologist who wrote that um
we spend our lives re repeating the
cycles that are established in childhood
and trying to correct them lives doing
that
because you don't you don't correct it
the first time you keep coming back to
that
and keep trying to make it perfect but
um
i am i'm much less anxious than i used
to be
much less i got that down to a tolerable
level
uh that's that's very important
do you i know you go through this
because you go to the conventions and
i've seen you at signings we were in
ireland together in dublin
and you know people are constantly
saying you know
for me they're like oh say i am the
villain of the story
do you hear you know i'm batman i want
to hear that you hear it all the time
right so
i'm sure it's got i mean look you love
it but you've done it so much
do you have to remind yourself when
you're getting annoyed that this is just
a gift that you just
have to suck it up i mean it's got to
get annoying sometimes
that doesn't get annoying because i know
how lucky i am
good what gets annoying is when people
get
really intrusive um
about something and and that that's when
i have to
take a breath and and and remind myself
um
how lucky i am and to not react
um i was at khan i was at a con recently
and i was sitting waiting
um for a car i think to pick me up and
this guy was just standing in front of
me with a camera
and just kept following me with the
camera just wouldn't
stop following me with the camera i said
excuse me i'm not
i'm i'm off now you know i'm going home
and he wouldn't stop
and he just kept it over and finally i
snapped him i said would you
turn that [ __ ] thing off and as soon
as i did it i thought okay that's the
moment that's going to go on
on instagram or something you know
that's the moment that's gonna did it
did it go on there
no no it never never did but i was so
sure it would because
he was just pushed and pushed and pushed
and pushed and pushed and
he got the reaction he wanted you know
and i and i fell into it
um because i just felt my space was so
invaded right but um i have such great
fans i have such
incredible support from the fans that i
i am so appreciative when they come to
the commons i love going to the concert
yeah i do too
i think you and i i mean i don't think
everybody loves it you do you're great
with the fans i've watched you you're
great
oh thank you i you know i just not
everybody is
really i don't i mean i guess i don't
notice because i just want to have fun
and i you know i
i think it's just part of me it's just
part of my personality it's just like
i'm here i have
and it's exhausting and that's part of
my personality that
even though i like that part about me
there's many parts i don't like
but certainly when i'm on set and i'm
working
i always feel like in between i'm i'm
laughing i'm joking i'm doing it
and i exhaust myself yeah all the other
actors go to their trailers and they
rest kevin conroy goes and he reads a
script or a book
or takes a nap not michael rosenbaum
he's hanging out with the grips
and the [ __ ] uh set design hey guys
everyone loves you yes but it's
torturing me i am this hermit because
i'm back in my room reading a book
inside of you is supported by better
help online counseling
i just talked about these guys in the
intro they didn't even tell me i had to
but uh i liked them so much i did it's
it's
very important during these times
especially i struggle i i talk about it
in the beginning i was telling you i was
like
fancy things weren't going right you
know and i live alone so who am i going
to talk to
better help online counseling like if
you're struggling with anxiety or
depression or stress right now
you're absolutely not alone better help
offers online licensed professional
counselors who are trained to listen
and help counselors specialize in many
diverse areas including as i said
depression anxiety but also grief
relationship conflicts
and much much more all you do is fill
out a questionnaire
to help assess your specific needs and
get matched with the counselor
in under 48 hours talk with your
counselor in a safe and private online
environment at your convenience from
wherever you're comfortable
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages they
can't get enough messages from me
everything you share of course is
confidential and if for any reason
you're unhappy with your counselor you
can request a new one at any time no
additional charge
join the million people who are taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced better help
professional with so many people using
betterhelp they're currently recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
betterhelp is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10
off your first month with a discount
code inside
get started today at betterhelp.com
slash
inside that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash i-n-s-i-d-e
well you know here's a good question oh
i'm gonna compliment myself before i ask
it
here's a good question you know uh no
it's not
it's it's one of those things i mean
look at you juilliard and you've done
all these
plays and worked with the greatest and
so and then
who had ever thought you'd become this
uh
amazing have this extensive over career
like that that's like has made you
famous in so many ways right
what was the likelihood of a new york
actor
who primarily did classics i worked for
joe papp at the public san diego
shakespeare hartford station a lot of
regional theater did a lot of theater
on broadway and off broadway but a
classically trained actor
what were the odds of the first
animated audition he's invited to do
is the animation of batman the first
audition i went on
for a voiceover and you didn't even want
to audition for that role i wanted to
audition for for book
because i thought those are the
character the character you know i could
be a really good character
i thought that would be a more fun
character and because of the kind of
roles i played
edgar in lear edmond in lear um
achilles orestes uh prince hal
all of these classic epic heroes that
the one role they would want me to read
for is
batman who is of all the dc characters
of all the animated universe he
is a classic shakespearean type of actor
his whole life drama is a greek drama i
mean it's so
epic it's so his parents killed
all right yeah it's a great drama when
bruce tim
was describing to me the character
because the only batman i knew was the
adam west batman from the 60s and bruce
said no no no that's not what we're
doing we lo everyone loves adam west but
that's not what we're doing
he said no and he described to me the
character the tragedy of the background
so i just put myself into you know just
putting my imagination in the booth i
went to this place
and you know this dark kind of rooty boy
and i sort of found this character
just in the audition just improvising
and they essentially hired me on the
spot
they'd seen over 500 people and i found
out from andrea
afterwards the casting director andre
romano who we love that
i had been recommended by a new york
casting agent
anthony borneo who she knew
because she said to anthony i'm going
crazy i can't find a batman
we've seen hundreds of people and he
said well there's this really
interesting
new york actor who does classics and
he might be really interesting to you so
that's the kind of chance
that wouldn't happen now
because everything's stunt casted now
everything's about starcasting
they were willing to look at an actor
that no one had ever heard of
but who had the right instinct for the
role
and brought the character to life i
honestly don't think i would probably
get the role today
um and that's the sad thing about the
way the business has evolved
but that was such a lucky moment for me
because it was also the first show where
they broke away
from that daytime goofy
um broad cartoony anime
animation that had been done while we
were kids growing up
and they were willing to go to this dark
dramatic epic film noir
incredible scripts full symphony score
big
cast of actors it was like doing a movie
every week
it was such a huge departure for warner
brothers and the only reason they did it
was because
gene mccurdy wanted to do it and bruce
tim
uh wanted to do it and eric grigonski
and paul
all the people that got involved were so
excited about doing this
but they knew they were doing something
revolutionary it hadn't been done
and what are the odds that i would
happen to be in la i was a new york
actor
i happened to be in l.a doing a pilot
for a show that's the only reason you
went in if you were not in la you
probably would have got this role no
i wouldn't have gotten it so everything
about it was so
fortuitous it was so it was such an odd
thing that happened and that it led to a
you know
29 years of being involved with this
character how soon did your life
change right after you got it how long
did it take before you noticed this is
this is some this is a difference
something's happening a long time
because
this was 91 when we started recording it
and we would do it in this funky little
recording studio in um
los feliz of the rowena studio
and um we weren't even on the warner
brothers lot so we were like this little
gorilla group
of performers you know off on our own
and we didn't know what it was going to
look like
because you know you do the voices first
you don't know for six months till it
comes back from the animators
it's going to look like so for those
first six months
we didn't know anything about what was
going on we saw sketches but no one had
any idea it was going to be all painted
on black
it was going to be this massive artistic
endeavor with this full symphony sport
i didn't know that so i was just
improvising this character um
so it was before the internet
so you couldn't google kevin conrad or
batman
you know it was when voice overs were
still a very anonymous job
and i was used to it being anonymous and
um
i was cool with that who is your
favorite to work with in terms of like
you have favorites but to other voice
actors who just really loved their
passion and they were fun
and it was easy besides me who else or
my
[Music]
i absolutely mean me i mean like even
like in the early 90s i mean you were
working with like hamel
right to be honest so much fun right
hands down you know this
just a brilliant
crazy complicated guy and lovable as
hell
generous no ego gets in the way
yeah loves other actors one of my
favorite images of martin
is looking over at him and seeing him
like watching the others we're all
recording together
and he's in the booth and i'm looking at
him he's watching another actor perform
he's like this
he looked like a little kid looking in a
candy candy store he's like excited this
big
movie and i thought that's that's hannah
he so loves actors
that's so cool because most people don't
do that right most people are going
oh yeah come on yeah well it's my turn
or
something and and he's yeah he's
cheering them on it's just it's a good
thing to
to do to to support your other actors to
cheer them on you know it's the right
instinct to have because he knows
that the better i am the better he'll be
because acting is reacting yeah if
you're getting a great performance you
have so much more to get to respond to
and to give to
and will it will draw out of you but if
you're working with a piece of wood
you know someone who's giving you
nothing it's
it's a hundred times harder you know
that is that why you called me wood
rosenwood that's what we call you woody
wait a
wait a minute no michael
you are anything but well i don't know
you know when you did the uh when you
did batwoman which was recent
for the infinite universe infinite uh
what crisis on infinite
crisis on infinite earth when they
called you
and said kevin live action we want you
to be
batman he's a bad bad batman
on this world in this universe is
did at first were you thinking [ __ ] now
no immediately what's the first thought
that came to you no
effects well they didn't tell me
anything about the batman
they just said he was a batman in the
future it was old
bruce wayne and i said you mean like in
batman beyond old bruce wayne they said
well no he's not 80
but he's he's older and he's in bad
shape
and um and you're like thanks
i mean what the [ __ ] hey man
um they don't you know they're so
guarded with their scripts the studios
as you know
uh they don't give them out so they
didn't give me anything
i got the script basically when i was
about to get on a plane to fly to
vancouver to do the show
i haven't seen anything but you said yes
and i said yes because
i was so excited to do something on
camera again
i was so excited how long has it been 25
years
25 years is that sort of by choice or
did
you were you always pursuing that or did
you just kind of say yeah i'm doing this
i love my life
i'll do plays i'm not interested really
in that or was it something like [ __ ]
come on
i got a little bit older
uh roles got more
fewer and i moved back to new york
uh because i had been living in l.a for
a while because as i said i
inherited a brother that i took care of
so um
he lived in connecticut and um so i had
to be near him
so that meant doing more theater and um
i didn't get any on camera work after
that it just stopped
so i started doing more and more voice
work all right so when you suit up as
batman
and you're standing there on set live
action
are you nervous oh i was nervous
are you feeling things you haven't felt
in a long time oh yeah well what was
weird about it also was they had that
exoskeleton did you see it
yeah it was in this suit of armor sort
of that was a
external spine right because his back
had been broken by superman
and i didn't know that was gonna happen
so
this is full of surprises i didn't know
i was gonna try and kill
supergirl um he was dark
he was dark didn't you kill superman on
that on that
universe then you kill superman yeah the
fans were not happy about it
they didn't like seeing that
version of bruce wayne but they liked
seeing you but for me it was fun
it was a lot of fun to sort of stretch
my
acting chops a little bit do you want to
do it again are you ready to go
i would love to yeah producer was great
the cast
ruby rose everybody uh was fantastic
wonderful to work with but they do like
a movie a week
it's a massive undertaking quickly
quickly you know we didn't really talk
about robin williams but you know
you roomed with ronald williams you
almost room with christopher reeve
it was too expensive with chris was
chris you know i met him an
unbelievable man i mean a genuinely real
superman
do you and you almost roomed with him
but it was too expensive
he was rich did i tell you that nothing
i read it
you read it yeah where do people find
this stuff out i don't tell anyone this
stuff well obviously it's true
everything you read is true in
interviews people tell me things about
my career or my life and i think
i never told anyone that how did you
know well it just you said it was more
it was a little expensive so that's why
you couldn't room with them or something
yeah that's all it was oh i so wanted
that apartment it was a
it was a floor through of a loft
in soho in 73
and it was something like
i think it was like 700 a month or
something or 800
it would have been 400 each and that was
just way way way out of my league
i ended up getting a room in a rooming
house for 150 a month
can you believe that on the west side of
manhattan that was my first apartment
wow but um but i couldn't there was no
way i could swing it but i so
wanted to because he was an
upperclassman and he was really cool
and you know he was part of the whole
juilliard did he ask you to be his room
to be his roommate um i think he just
made him put it on the bulletin board
that he was looking for a roommate or
something right
but when i saw the floor through of this
loft and i had these
sliding glass doors i remember it was so
new york downtown dream apartment i
thought this would be so cool to have
but there was no way i was financially
going to do it
so um so robin and i ended up
splitting an apartment with with a
couple of other actors
so you lived and breathed like the same
i mean you guys were eating together
were you hanging out together you and
robin you were
all working together we were all working
together
we were living together i was 17
i was 18 i guess when i moved in with
robin
and he had already been through college
so he was like 22 or 23.
and five years doesn't make a lot of
difference between 40 and 45
but between 18 and 23 it's almost like a
different gender it is
yeah i was so much younger than him um
in terms of life experience i mean he
was going
he was doing stand-up mine on the steps
of the metropolitan museum that's where
he would go
on weekends to make money
i would have been petrified to do that
at that point in my life
i i just couldn't do that um
and he was doing these um
performances during in school of these
characters
he was a great great great character as
you saw in like mrs doubtfire
and moscow on the hudson um but that was
really his strong
his strength was character and he would
create these characters at the age of 23
he did like an 85 year old man and it
was totally convincing
he was lost in that man i also always
imagined him someone like me at the time
probably
running around the house naked doing
goofy things making everyone laugh
was he like that because i remember i
heard like morgan mindy was always naked
walking around
opening his robe it was just different
time it wasn't he wasn't trying to be a
perv he was just trying to be a fun
stupid clown
you know he was a clown the thing about
robin that was a little uh difficult to
live with is it it never turned off
never he was always what you saw
that was not um
something that he turned on it was just
the on switch was always on
um and in the middle of the night you'd
wake up and you'd hear voices coming
from his bedroom
and there'd be different characters in
there like the whole family was in there
but it was just robin and he was just
having these conversations with these
characters
he couldn't turn it off and that's got
to be hard to live with
do you think that it was hard for him
too he knew it yes yes
um i think the reason he couldn't turn
it off was because
he was much more comfortable in that
skin than he was in his own skin
it was hard for robin to just be robin
i found it was one night
he left juilliard early because of a
very
very um
dramatic breakup
uh with a girlfriend in california
and he had leaving and he would have
these
five-hour phone calls with her in the
middle of the night
and that was back when you were paying
you know mob l by the minute
so this was this was insane what was
going on it was really insane
and the night that she split up with him
he had a meltdown
and i saw all of that performance
bravado manic energy
melt and he became this
shaking
keening
child the sound was coming out of him
that was like
the only word i can think of is keening
from the irish plays
um and all i could do was hold him
and just hold him there was nothing i
could say he was shaking
and i realized he was losing control
and i thought this is the closest i've
ever seen him be
honest be him he wasn't performing
and i was holding him like you would
your son
and um we just i was afraid to let go
it's afraid what happened
eventually put him to bed but that was
the most intimate moment we ever had
the most honest moment we ever had and
we never spoke of it after that
because i think he was embarrassed i
could see that because everybody every
time you see him he was always on always
always on and that was a moment where
you're like he
did he doesn't have control right now
this is the first time in his life
and it was nice that you were there from
all right this is really quick this is
the end this is by the way
this is to me this is one of the most
extraordinary
interviews i've had i i i no no it is
because
you have touched me and you have made me
really think and
um your stories
i am so i'm captivated by them i could i
could see
these these certain moments in your life
whether it's robin or whether it's your
father or whether it's the the play when
you're having a fight with brian or
the profound thing he said or when you
first got batman it's
for the first time i think that i'm
really like i'm so lost in it that i
feel like
maybe this is my true first episode of
where i feel like i'm really inside of
someone so thank you for that
thank you okay these are it's called
[ __ ] talking questions these are just my
patreons they're patrons they they
there's a thing called patreon and they
get to ask questions so this is spitfire
you just
hammer mount ashley g would you well
this is easy would you do more live
action roles like the crossover or
or just stick to a lot of voiceover
mostly voice over acting well no i would
love to do more live action
i would love it ryan c inspirations
did you use for voicing batman and you
talk about you know shakespeare and
things like that but what were your real
inspirations did you it was just
kind of off the cuff it was so off the
cuff it really was it was just
but in terms of inspiration for a lot of
the role
um because bruce wayne's issues are with
his parents
they're unresolved issues and i have to
say i have gone back to moments
um in my childhood with
especially my father who i still have a
lot of emotion for
um it was a much darker moment with my
father when i was about
16 where he tried to kill himself and i
was the one who was sent to
um identify him and talk to the police
and
pick up his car and stuff and um
it was a very emotional night for me
very very emotional
it took me a long time to get past that
um
it was very bloody and um
i've i've gone there periodically
in recordings in fact i did at one point
andrea stopped the recording and she
came into the booth
you know she doesn't do that no she put
her arms around me and she said i don't
know where you just went but it was
unbelievable are you okay
because i was just i was just weeping
wow yeah i'm okay she said i don't think
so
she said let's take a break everybody
you know andrea doesn't ever do that
when she loves you it doesn't matter
i i mean i j i have always felt that
with her that i could call her right now
and her and rogerio would just be there
in a second
you know they've come to thanksgiving
dinners and people like who are these
these that's andre and roger who
the [ __ ] you think it is but that's
that's amazing and i think that a lot of
most of the great actors probably
the great actors have something to you
know
maybe that's why we had such dysfunction
if we didn't if we didn't have things in
our life that happened
you wouldn't have gotten batman you
wouldn't have been able to emote all
these things but maybe on the flip side
you had a really healthy happy fun
childhood
and you would have worked as a teacher
in uh [ __ ] uh westbury
and everything
you know and i think that too i'm like
you know lex luthor oh my god you know
and i've certainly tapped into a lot of
dad stuff with john glover who you
worked with who we love
and you tap in and when you can tap in
it is something special and something
really
hard sometimes and it just brings out a
lot of so many shows together through
the years
first thing we did was a kennedy mini
series i played teddy kennedy
and he played one of the family um
extended family people it was with uh
uh it was a huge cast for the bbc and
cbs
big mini series martin sheehan and john
shay and blair brown this great cat
and then we did the george washington
miniseries
with another massive cast and then we
did
a production of um measure for measure
much ado
at san diego shakespeare festival and
then lear he played edgar and i played
edmond and um
so we've you know and then of course all
the batman stuff
i've known john for like 40 years well
he's crazy
oh all right uh stephanie besides batman
what other roles would you uh want to
pursue
where do you start i'd love to play
everything
um oh god
i wouldn't know where to start i mean
you know that actors want to do
everything i i the most wonderful thing
happened recently
uh paul dini and alan burnett have
started doing a new
uh incarnation of batman the animated
series comic books
they've come out with a new series of
comic books and
um they asked me to do a live reading
um of the first issue did you just do
that
i just did it yeah i said well which
character and they said well would you
do
like a reading of all the characters i
said oh my god would i love that i would
love that
so i did the cover to cover reading of
it playing all the characters
it was so much fun it was like an actor
playground it was so much fun
that's glorious delsi bader dietrich
dietrich's wife um sent me an email
after that and she said
we really love your drunk socialite she
was great
uh roxy who was influential in your life
your choice to become an actor maybe
that's two questions maybe it's one
it's a different story when i switched
from catholic schools which i had gone
to as a kid
to public schools because we moved to a
different town they didn't have a
catholic school
i was very um
as i said earlier i was a very uptight
kid i was very
i was a nuts basically because of my
home but also because of the school
i mean we had you know it was all school
catholic where you
wear a you know a uniform every day
you do everything to clickers in the
hallway it was very
nuns and full habits it was very old
school mass every morning
and um i suddenly was thrown into this
crazy
public school and i couldn't adjust
i could not adjust i could not function
i didn't know how to function
and they didn't know what to do with me
they thought there might be something
wrong with me and they were suggesting
my parents sent me to
um some kind of remedial school because
they thought there was something wrong
with it
and this english teacher assigned us
julius caesar this is in seventh grade
and i went home and i'd never seen a
play i'd never read a play i didn't know
anything about the beard
i read it i sat down it was like i
understood
what shakespeare was saying i just got
it
i've never even seen shakespeare i've
never seen iambic pentameter
it was weird that's weird because i yeah
and i came in the next day and i was
exploding ready to talk about
and i came in with all this energy and
she said
wait wait wait wait wait um
why don't you come to my last period
class it's a
it's an advanced placement class i want
you to get involved in that conversation
so i came to her last class and i was
like taking over the room
no brutus was saying this don't you know
what this means
and she said i want you to come with me
and she took me to the guidance
counselor she said
i'm going to suggest we put him in all
advanced placement classes i think we
have not understood this yet
and i also want you to audition for the
school play
her name was joyce wells she was an
english teacher
joyce welsh joyce wilkes welcome she
saved my life
she saw something in me that no one else
had seen
and she took that day that moment and
said we're putting you in different
classes
and we're putting you in the school play
and i ended up getting the lead
of the play our town
and then i got then i
ended up doing all the plays and then it
just sort of took over my life
i got on a stage and where most kids who
are 12
get stage fright freeze
i suddenly all my nervous energy all my
tension all my anxiety that i felt in my
home
melted away and i
felt
so at home wow in that
warm glow that comes on you on stage
i felt so liberated theater saved you
it literally saved me and i still feel
that way when i get on a stage
i am so much more comfortable on a stage
than i am off the stage
off stage i'm more circumspect
and more guarded much more guarded but
i'm on stage i just
i can do anything i found that when i
was 12.
what are the chances of that happening
what were the chances of my meeting that
that that wonderful teacher think about
things think about that think about what
are the odds that you're there for pilot
season and you just go and read for
batman
look at the odds of all the what are the
odds at that moment brian said you know
what this is advice i'll give you the
one piece of advice you took from
someone who
was kind of volatile and you didn't
really you know you loved him but you
didn't really
you know yeah and these moments in a way
that gets you through they help you
these little
he gave you that one moment which was so
huge in your life it resonated
through my whole life yeah and someone
saw mrs wilkes
it was mrs uh you know mrs johnson who
was mrs peter noster or mrs meyer or
the few people or the one casting
director who believed in me
it's that one those very few people
which can change
the the course of how things go with
your life i mean it's just
incredible isn't it amazing it really is
come up to me
at the chicago comic con i've never
forgotten this
and you've had this happen she just said
can i hug you
i really have to hug you she said you
mean
so much to me i said of course and i
gave her a hug and i was figuring you
know it's just a fan hug
she started to cry getting really
emotional
and i said it's okay it's okay i said
it's she said no you don't understand
what you did for me
she said i i grew up in the projects on
the south side of chicago
and every kid i knew growing up
is either in jail dead
or on drugs she said i got out
because you were there for me every
afternoon
because my parents were working two and
three jobs every day they were not home
they were too busy trying to make money
and you were the safe space for me every
day
and i learned so much from you
she was putting that all into me but it
was batman it was the character
show all right as an actor you think
oh my god the effect that you can have
on someone
is such a blessing because you know
you're so involved with
doing the role getting the role
performing the role
you tend to forget what effect it's
having on someone
and how something you do
might save a child's life
like that teacher saved my life yeah as
far as she was concerned she was just
doing her job that day
or brian when he gave me that bit of
advice he was just you know
tossing off a pearl of wisdom he didn't
know would resonate with me for the rest
of my life
we can all have such a profound effect
on each other
when we don't know it yeah that's why
you always have to resist that impulse
to be short with someone you know what i
mean
to let your impatience get the better of
you
yeah because we're human we all get
impatient
sure but you can't you can't
yeah and it took a long time for me not
a not a long time but
i didn't i was appreciative i was
grateful
but there was a moment where i just go
like how could my performance
well how could something i've done it as
an actor
helps someone in their life that doesn't
make any sense i'm just a show it's just
it's just you watch it and yeah and so i
didn't i couldn't
understand it but then slowly
when people who you know soldiers said
hey
our paul platoon in iraq
we had the dvds of smallville that's all
we used to watch and it got us through
and you don't understand
or someone says hey my dad you know
that's all we had was our tuesday night
smallville and he died he died of cancer
but that's
that was our moment and then i start to
think about it and it gives me
goosebumps like
wow we do have an impact
oh yeah and and and by the way and it's
when you know it and you
you can do more well if this has an
impact what else can i do to help
because you can you could do we just did
an omaze thing for uh
ronald mcdonald house tom kristen and i
got together and raised a bunch of money
for
just because we were on a show if it's
that easy keep it coming
i did a series called tour of duty oh
yeah
it was a great show captain the balloon
was the first vietnam show
on tv and it really resonated with
vietnam vets and i would uh because i
was the captain
i was the one who at the beginning of
the episode would tell everyone what to
do
and at the end of the episode would say
good work guys
i wasn't in the middle of the shows
right so i had a lot of down time
so i would take advantage of that and i
would go do appearances for the vva
around the country at different centers
and the experience of being
in these centers with these guys who
were
devoted to the show
there was one it was either an iowa
maybe it was i were in nebraska
and a guy
they were having a rap session which
they
organized because i was going to be
there
and we all talked about how the show was
affecting them
with their experiences from the war and
it was just a
talk and this guy came
in i saw everyone react when he came
in i wondered what the reaction was and
he just sat in the circle
and then he suddenly started saying
you don't know you don't know
you don't know what it was like you
don't know what i
saw i tried to stop him i tried to stop
him
and he just was back somewhere else
and one guy put his arm around his
back and then another guy put his arm
around his back and then i got up
and started and we ended up making this
huge
cocoon around this guy who
started wailing
wailing and broke down
and then the organizer the guy ran the
vietnam center there the the vet center
took him aside with a group and he came
back to me and said
we've been trying to reach that guy for
years
we could never get him to come in we
knew about it
and he must have heard about
your being here today and
that was a major breakthrough for him no
one's
ever been able to reach him
i thought
the effect that
the performances we do can have on
people
is so extraordinary it's it's so
humbling
yeah and it's also what i gather from
that is i don't know what i would have
done and it's like
at least i did something that
does can have an effect and does have an
effect and it's nice because i never
thought i'd have an effect
on anybody's life so it sure is uh
look this is this has been extraordinary
i've learned so much from you and i i
told you i go no
kevin 45 minutes an hour that's all i
need and then i just can't stop
i can't [ __ ] stop talking to you i i
look i i love this and i know people are
gonna
they're gonna go crazy because it's just
real and visceral and
and that's what the listeners want they
don't it's not just a show we're like
hey man so
tell me how you partied with so it's
it's it's become this
just kind of like how you get through
life and it helps people out there you'd
be surprised by your story
will help so many people just about your
dad relating to that or
alcoholism or whatever it is it is um
i really appreciate you i really enjoyed
it thank you were you worried were you
like oh [ __ ] rosenbaum
what's he gonna ask me what is this
beautiful house by the way
thank you what if it's a set all right
break it down let's break it down
the interview the interview's over
hey kevin thank you for allowing me
inside of you that's what we say at the
end of these interviews
and uh i wish you the best and uh i
can't wait to see you again
and i'll keep in touch i'll keep bugging
you okay see you soon
beautiful man honestly i i thought i was
gonna get emotional a few times when he
talks about his dad that that moment
with his father is just
incredible and the guy that was a kind
of problem working with and he gets this
advice it's amazing that you can even
get advice from people you don't like
or maybe he didn't say didn't like him
but people that you might at the time
it's hard to work with it's hard to do
you know um
[Music]
gotta look at the bright side of things
i suppose you just
you just do shout out to the patrons
great episodes coming up i told you some
big
big news coming and i can't wait to
announce it it's just a it's a really
cool thing and uh i hope it uh
i hope it should be a great thing and uh
i just want to say thank you again for
all the support and love and i know it's
uh
i i i don't get political sometimes i
mention things but i i don't do that
i think you want to get away from that
and uh if you know
there's always that fear people are
going to leave if you talk well you know
no one wants to hear politics i get it
you know
we are going rob danson and i um thank
you for watching our stage it's and
we're playing music and we're always
looking for new covers and playing
originals and
we'll be doing one in a couple of weeks
so look for that on my instagram another
virtual
convention coming out i'm on cameo if
anybody wants a cameo
you gotta [ __ ] yourself out a little
bit i mean i'm out there this is what
i'm doing i'm at home like you guys
you gotta figure things to entertain
things to do to
keep your spirits up keep them busy i've
had a lot of problems with my dog
um irv has had a lot of problems and
i've taken to the vet probably
i don't know 10 to 15 vets in the last
couple weeks and uh from
surgeons to and uh we're figuring it out
and then i realized one of my friends
said do you think maybe he's just
getting old and i go no
don't you dare don't he is old it's
getting old
you know and um i get upset i'm like you
know i'm like
come on buddy what am i what am i i
think he's going to all sudden
rip off his fur and it's a big super s
in the middle and he's going to go
i was kidding here i am he's old man i
got to just
uh got to accept that and i got to give
him the best life he could have
and um you know i just bought this thing
to help him get into the car
you know the uh it's a pet loader
so called pet loader it's just these
little stairs they just hold the
you know it's like a briefcase but un
you know on dues
undoes itself i can't it just when you
open it up
uh they're like little stairs into the
truck and um it helps them
and uh everybody just loves that dog
including me
i think that's what makes me the most
sad is that uh you know
when that time comes i think everybody
knows
erv all my friends my celebrity friends
my fans
listeners my everybody my family it's
erv and i just lost my grandfather in
november and now
i've got this old irv dog you know
trying to i hope he doesn't understand
what i'm saying for some reason i think
he gets it
he's like dude come on man i'm in the
other room
shout out to my uncle warren who has the
pet show go to warren eckstein
if you want to listen to some good stuff
you have any pet problems he's amazing
um i've been watching the show alone not
alone well i am alone watching a show
called alone on history channel i just
love it
i started with episode six the arctic
and i fell in love with it
and um let's just say
i loved it so much that i was emotional
and i got a hold of the winner and
said you gotta be on the podcast and
they said sure so the winner of steven's
season six alone is going to be on the
podcast soon
i'm very excited about that talk about
someone facing adversity
uh all right let me give the shout outs
to patreon thank you so much ryan cue
that music baby
how about a little left on laurel take
him out man how about a little bit of uh
i don't know so whatever you want man
yeah that one ryan that's good stuff
thank you guys again for listening to
the podcast i'm telling you
please tell everybody you know make them
subscribe do all that stuff without you
uh i'm not here and i like to be here
this has become my sort of
i don't know it's my escape talking to
you guys
i'm like grizzly man remember grizzly
man he recorded all this stuff with the
bears and
oh then he gets killed by the bears at
the end yeah let's not refer to that
patreons nancy d leah asked trisha f
sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h lauren g nico p barry i angelina
g
lee robin asked jerry w emily k bobby
robert b
jason w stephen j kristen k amelia o
allison l
tom and jess j lucas m raj
joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m hamza b jennifer n stacy b
carly t jennifer s janelle b tabitha 272
kimberly e crystal h
mike e marissa and ramira
beth b chris f sarah f getting in sexy
voice now
chad w leanne p jackie p rodrigo
s ray rachen
maya p megan d jennifer c
maddie s tiffany i kendrick f ashley e
margie m thomas t matt w belinda and
benjamin r
lisa j kevin v robert s nicole m
amber f james r chris h you guys
are amazing all my patrons are amazing
and these guys go above and beyond uh
top tiers
thank you top tiers for uh keeping the
show alive
and um you know i appreciate you
i got some new merch coming uh as well
um
so inside of you store we've got great
stuff i just sold out of autographed
mugs
if you want an autographed mug there's
they're available they're coming in the
mail any day but they'll probably go
through those pretty quickly they uh
they went through quickly uh also i got
some other items
and telling you guys on patreon um
the top tiers uh you'll be getting some
of these products
you know because those merch boxes the
top tiers you'll be getting these things
so you don't have to get them i'm just
giving you a heads up
so guys thank you for allowing me to be
inside each and every one of you
spread the word and uh thanks for tuning
in i hope you continue to do so
i'm here if you are so thanks